hello everybody and welcome to another
moneymaking guide today I'm going to be
showing you an easy way uh you can make
actually about 1.3 mil in an hour with
just a pretty uh reasonable herblore
requirement um and what we're going to
be doing is making unfinished potions
it's pretty AFK actually really easy to
do and yeah I'll show you let's get
started okay so the most important part
about this uh method is to be able to
figure out what herbs will make the most
profitable
potions and to do that it's pretty
simple uh to start off you will need a
herblore level um the one I got to is 55
to make the Quorum potions cuz I found
the Quorum and the RAR potions tend to
have the best margins on them I can see
here kind of a list calculation for you
it varies a lot but the qu potion Renard
potion works pretty well snap dragon and
lad does as well but it does have a
higher herbl requirement but for cor
potions only going to be 55 for R our
potions it's only like 25 or uh 38 sorry
so still not very high and yeah let's go
ahead and just check one of them quickly
so what we're going to do is buy and
sell one of the cleaned herbs to begin
with and after that you're going to buy
the unfinished version of the potion so
unfinished RAR potion in this
case okay so it's pretty simple uh vs
are about 35 GP each so we'll get our
calculator open so we're going to take
749 is what we sell the unfinished RAR
potions for take off 6800 and 35 so that
would leave us with 214 GP on each
potion we'd be making times that by you
can do about 2500 in an hour be 535k so
not too bad um we'll do a little
searching and see if we can find a
better margin okay so we did find that
the qun potion definitely has the best
margin right now uh we can sell the corn
potions for about
4K and we can buy the clean qums for
about 3500 that leaves us this with
about a 500 GP margin now we times it by
1250 cuz that's how much we had to spend
at the time that should only take us
about half an hour uh so we'll see how
much we can actually make in half an
hour here because we right now on this
account we only have the cash for um
half an hour worth of making the potions
I guess so we'll go put an offer in for
1,250 qus and we'll come back uh when
they buy okay so we bought all the
forums uh for 3520 uh we also went and
bought 1,250 vials only five coins each
I have no idea why I thought they are 35
uh but even cheaper only five coins each
for the vial of water so now we're going
to go ahead and quickly just recheck the
corn potion and it looks like it's still
around 4K uh which is a very good margin
so again you do really have to check
these things in advance just go have a
look at all the herbs What potions they
make I take into account there's a bit
of a different herb blower level but if
you get 55 you will be able to do a
couple that are
profitable and uh yeah it's really easy
really AFK all you're going to do is
withdraw 14 of each um of the herb and
vials um the only problem with this is
you're not getting any experience uh but
if you can make over a mill an hour I
definitely would take advantage of this
way easier than actually cleaning the
herbs which is very click intensive it
kind of hurts your hand so yeah you just
click them together make all and that is
it so we'll come back when uh We've made
the potions okay so it's actually only
been about a little under 20 minutes and
I've done about 2/3 of all the potions
so I did the calculation of when I was
really doing it as quickly as possible
so if you're really paying attention you
could do about 3,000 potions in an hour
um more likely you'll do about
2500 um so yeah if you're kind of just
doing it casually 2500 would be expected
to be done in an hour not how manyy
we're going to go for here and yeah
we'll just finish up the rest of the
potions and we'll see how much we
actually made okay there we go guys we
finished uh combining all the potions
just under a half an hour to do it all
and it really was not bad like it didn't
hurt my hands or anything I they just
did it for you you don't have to click a
bunch you probably have to just click
every 10 seconds or so uh so we're going
to pop him in here for about 4K uh which
should leave us with about 600k in
profit in half an hour uh but we'll go
ahead make sure these sell and uh we'll
come back with a final total okay guys
so we've sold all the corn potions for
4,18 coins each that is going to leave
us with I think about a 600k profit yeah
612 and that only took us about half an
hour so in an hour would expect to make
about 1.2 mil uh to 1.3 mil depending on
what the herbs are at now of course this
will vary a lot on the time and day uh
but that's why it's best to look at a
bunch of different herbs uh when you're
looking for unfinished potions to make
so you can see here I have kind of a
quick list of them it's going to show
you the approximate profits um but you
can calculate them yourself very easily
using the way I showed you at the
beginning
um the benefits of this method is uh the
money obviously no herblore experience
um but it doesn't really require very
high herblore level I'd recommend
getting it to about 55 uh then you can
do two or three potions that are usually
pretty profitable all right guys I hope
you enjoyed the video uh if you want to
see more like this toss video like and I
will see you guys in the next
[Music]
episode